hello there welcome to the world of
competitive Pokemon my name is Callie
and I hope you'll call me the Pokemon
professor after this series I really
love Pokemon and competitive pokemon in
particular is one of my favorite things
but a lot of people haven't even tried
it because it can be kind of
intimidating
that said sword and shield have made it
easier than ever to actually get started
and hopefully I can help with the rest
in this short series I'm gonna walk you
through everything you need to know so
you can breed the perfect Pokemon make
your own team and have fun battling
[Music]
to start off we have to talk about what
competitive Pokemon even is there's all
kinds of unofficial competitive formats
out there but the official championship
format called VGC is the main one I'll
be focusing on all VGC battles are
double battles each player brings a
battle team of six Pokemon and you pick
four to use in the battle based on which
Pokemon are on your opponent's team you
can't have any repeat Pokemon or held
items on your team in certain Pokemon
like new are banned entirely so the
exact list varies from season to season
in a regular pokemon battle you probably
think about type matchups the raw power
of an attack and physical versus special
damage but when you're playing
competitively there's a lot more
considerations to deal with speed
weather move priority supporting moves
and Dynomax aim just to name a few like
I said it can all seem kind of
intimidating so let's just start by
looking at one pokemon and go from there
well - I have to drag a pulse here both
at level 100 but their stats are
actually pretty different bear with me
because once you understand stats
understanding everything else about
competitive pokemon will get a lot
easier you're probably familiar with the
six battle stats HP attack defense
special attack special defense and seed
each species of Pokemon has a general
base value for each stat that determines
its overall strengths and weaknesses the
average Drago pulp for example has an
exceptionally high speed stat great
attack very good special attack and then
middling stats in HP in the defenses but
when you look at the actual numbers
these two dragon polls have very
different stats individual Pokemon vary
within their species for a few reasons
the first is their IVs or individual
values these are the under-the-hood
numbers that go a long way in
determining an individual Pokemon stats
they're basically the pokemons genes IVs
range from 0 to 31 but in game you can
see them represented with the words if
you've unlocked the judge function in
the Pokemon box to do that you have to
beat the game and then get 6 wins in the
battle tower if it says best that means
it's a perfect 31 if it says no good
that's a flat 0 you generally don't want
anything in between the first dragon pol
has five perfect IVs with a pretty good
Special Attack stat while the second has
four perfect IVs with pretty good attack
and old
decent speed if we just compare speed
for now it's pretty clear that the
second dragon pole is gonna be slower
than the first but even with a bad speed
IV the second dragon pole is still gonna
be faster than a generally slow Pokemon
like slow poke it's just slow for a
draggable pokemon also have one of 25
nature's that affect how their stats
grow most nature's boost one stat and
hinder another though a few are neutral
you can easily tell what a nature does
without looking it up by looking at the
Pokemon stats the boosted stat will be
written in red while the hindered stat
will be in blue the first dragon poll is
jolly which improves its speed at the
expense of its special attack while the
second is timid which boosts speed at
the expense of its physical attack
instead I'll explain this more in a
second the biggest difference between
these two dragon pulse is how they're
trained there's another set of semi
hidden numbers called effort values or
V's which also help determine a Pokemon
stats there's both a maximum number of
V's a pokemon can get overall and a
maximum it can get in any one stat you
can see the general distribution by
going to a Pokemon stats screen and
pressing X it'll be a darker yellow if
you haven't hit the overall max or blue
if you have an individual stats will
sparkle if they're maxed out pokemon
automatically get v's when battling
zigzagging on for example gives one
speed Eevee to each Pokemon that gained
experience from battling it during the
course of the main adventure you're
usually battling a variety of Pokemon
kind of at random rather than a bunch of
Zigzagoon in a row so the Pokemon you
use to beat the game will have a totally
random set of V's spread across all
their stats for competitive Pokemon
however you usually want Eevee is
concentrated in two or three of their
most important stats
that's because competitive players breed
and train their Pokemon very
specifically in order to take advantage
of that pokemons strengths unlike the
jack-of-all-trades Pokemon you likely
use to beat the game competitive Pokemon
usually have narrower roles some are
offensive some are defensive and some
activesupport in one way or another even
if offense isn't their main job most
competitive Pokemon further specialize
in either physical or special attack
offensive Pokemon can hit harder with
full Eevee investment in their stronger
attack stat while defensive Pokemon are
of course better off with Eevee
investment in their defense
so back to the draggable drag a pole is
actually one of the lucky pokemon that
has strong base stats in both attack and
special attack and with its incredible
speed it's a great candidate for a fast
hard-hitting attacker or special
attacker the first drag of pole is my
competitive attack build I bred it to
have five perfect stats except for
Special Attack and chose a nature that
hurts Special Attack and then I Eevee
trained it with full investment in speed
is hack it's very fast
and it can do a lot of damage which is
what I wanted the second drag of holt
has the makings of a special attacker
thanks to its IVs in nature but that was
actually just dumb luck I caught this
one in a raid and used it to finish the
story so it has a totally random
assortment of V's including way too many
in attack a given that its nature
actively hurts this attack it also knows
three physical moves and only one
special one because I didn't pay
attention at all when I was leveling it
up so even with almost perfect IVs and
the right nature this dragon pool isn't
competitive at all because numbers are
kind of abstract here's the in battle
effect of proper breeding and training I
had both dragga Poltz battle the same
melodic using the same move phantom
force which is a physical attack both
drag a bolts out speed this melodic even
though it has a perfect speed IV since
melodic space speed is much lower than
dragon pulse once the move hits you can
see a big difference in how much damage
the competitive dragon polt deals on the
left versus the regular one on the right
and in competitive battles every bit of
damage counts so to recap an individual
Pokemon stats are determined by a few
things first the base stats of its
species which stats it's naturally
strong or weakened overall second its
IVs how good each stat is relative to
those base species stats in simpler
terms is it the fastest it can be for
its species the slowest or something in
between third its nature which stat is
further improved by the pokemons nature
and which is lowered fourth
it's V's how the pokemon has been
trained I'll go over the math of this in
the breeding and training video but for
now all you need to know is that Eevee
investment further improve stat it's
essentially how you customize your
Pokemon like I said earlier
understanding how stats work will make
understanding everything else about
competitive Pokemon a lot easier so if
you have any questions feel free to ask
me on twitter at inky tojiko or in the
comments below the next episode is all
about battle strategies in the VGC so
stay tuned to games
but thanks for watching
[Music]